a while since we've seen that animation
earlier this week we learned President
Trump has already named his campaign
manager for the 2020 election we have
far less certainty about the other side
of the ticket tonight correspondent
Peter Doocy looks at some of the
possibilities for the Democrat
nomination battle the early search for a
Democrat who could beat Trump is
scattershot with dozens of names in the
mix the good thing is we've just built
two or three new hotels in Des Moines
and I think we're gonna need them
leading up to the caucuses because
they're gonna be a lot of candidates
first there's the Obama era throwbacks
former Vice President Joe Biden is first
among Democrats in a recent Quinnipiac
poll Obama himself has said he thinks
former Massachusetts governor Deval
Patrick would be a good president and
longtime Attorney General Eric Holder is
already talking himself up I think I've
got the guts the next category of
contenders the establishment Virginia's
former Governor Terry McAuliffe just
told the Washington free beacon there's
nobody better to take on Trump than him
California Governor Jerry Brown isn't
ruling out a run and New York Governor
Andrew Cuomo is already testing out anti
Trump attack lines while borrowing his
slogan if the party wants a progressive
there's plenty to pick from in the
Senate where every vote could be an
audition for left-wing primary voters
there's Bernie Sanders Kamala Harris
Elizabeth Warren sherrod Brown Kirsten
Gillibrand and Cory Booker who is
playing coy if it's mayors that motivate
the base there may be at least three
Mitch Landrieu formerly of New Orleans
Pete Budaj edge of South Bend and Eric
Garcetti from Los Angeles others rumors
want to leave LA for DC celebrities like
Oprah George Clooney even the rock
seriously would you run I'm seriously
considering it yes last but not least
the Democrats drawing attention for
booking flights to Iowa and New
Hampshire like former Missouri Secretary
of State Jason Kander Montana governor
steve bullock former HUD secretary
Julian Castro Maryland Congressman John
Delaney
was already declared and Massachusetts
congressman Seth Moulton just because
they come up doesn't necessarily mean
they're running this cycle but you know
in this day and age with Donald Trump
there anyone could be President so why
not at least think about it
that politically diverse group of
Democrats running reveals that nobody
knows what the base is gonna look like
and that is why the New Hampshire
Democratic Chairman ray Buckley tells me
he thinks the split in early states is
going to wind up being generational
because Democrats are gonna have a
choice between candidates in their 30s
and 40s versus some in their 60s and 70s
Bret twenty and twenty twenty maybe that
was twenty three clonise Peter thanks